[Music]
have any of you guys ever been a victim
of static cling mmm yeah of course is
that is that one a dryer sheet is stuck
on you know or touch your friends nose
like I've had underwear in my sleeve
once I'm like what the [ __ ] is this and
I'm like this story there's this story
that way viral like what the [ __ ] I'm
like oh Jesus you're like twenty of them
everyone else around is like Holies
toilet paper stuck on my ass once
dingleberry yeah I think I'm another
memory Hey okay so the story went viral
on Facebook this is the photo
accompanying it Oh cute in his jacket
yeah I will read through the caption
okay so the caption says oh my gosh and
then like the dead emoji moji and then
laughing emoji wait wait how many good
emojis there were two so it's dead
laughing dead laughing oh okay now you
have a visual and then oh my gosh is in
all caps and then there's a period after
every word I'm living for this here we
go
so then Asterix hunter hops in car mama
something funny happened today me oh
yeah what's that
he starts rolling up his pant leg and
pulls out my thumb I found this during
music class and then she says in all
caps you guys my frickin song was static
cling to the inside of his pant leg he
said he panicked and just shoved it back
up there and left it all day because he
thought I would pull on it back then he
said he kept pretending to tie his shoe
all day to shove them back up his pant
leg like crying laughing emoji after I
caught my breath I snatched them back
and said thanks son I mean if you don't
save your mom's song are you even a
mama's boy and I'm glad it happened
mom cuz I feel like if this was a
Portland mom she'd be like I think my
son wants to be a woman yeah yeah yeah
he had my underwear school he tried to
pass it off he wants to be a woman how
do I do this medically hashtag Portland
moms Wow hashtag I'm living for this why
did he just take it out and put it in
his pocket or backpack or something I
don't know boy how is that a bad boy I
guess for him and his innocent big mom
that's the way that he could save it for
it do rats that's bigger than his whole
body did wait it was stuck on his inside
right he couldn't pull it out put it in
his [ __ ] pocket like he couldn't be a
ninja and go to the bathroom and just
pull that [ __ ] out like if it
was you guys you guys would like we
should be like [ __ ] yeah put it over my
teacher I have a question just like a
show the whole time buddy if we put it
on and you know how girls back then used
to have the farm here on their thigh we
have it up like that we [ __ ] tie up
our shirts dog just going up like that I
still like that though that'd be
hilarious 20 years ago I know but hot
doesn't go away yeah it would girls do
this that's not 20 years ago that's
still hot yeah when they put the thong
like that yeah yeah nice it's like you
go pick it up dude sometimes sometimes
want me to get watching us crash has to
be on TV shows and then I look over and
I see your thong right up a little bit
and I'm like this yeah yeah when they
have moisture it's like you see this
line you see this part of the underwear
but for girls it disappears from here
well and dude it shapes their body so
yeah it's like this wow yeah that's yeah
I popping out of like high-waisted
bikini bottom but when guys do it it
looks like this yeah I'm always like
look that good but they win girls how
you need to rip it that's why this part
right here you see skin like that you
gotta wear some tighty-whiteys and do
that oh that's right oh my god I
remember being little I can't remember
how old but young enough and and then
like I would roll up the the side of the
in order to make it look like a string
so I could do that what [ __ ] kid show
it off I'm at home and I'm like oh I
don't actually walk around in public
like that you just kind of saw something
that you'd like something saw on TV what
is that like damn I think that was hot
too you see like the like the hot
anymore oh of course
look the Lea made it pop shops in like
some baggies you like rhinestone
overalls then you can see the underwear
Britney Spears and Christina Aguilera
did it a lot too
yeah Xtina stage I liked Xtina stage
pardon my Christine already I like that
let me tell you something guys true
trihard e with that when they did the
making of the video for dirty right it
was a whole behind-the-scenes thing
right and I recorded it because there
was like little moments in there that
they couldn't show in the video where
she was like ripped like practicing her
like twerking and [ __ ] and her skirt
would fly up like oh my god and I saved
it as the young end I would jerk off to
that tape of the recording making up
dirty and you've got a slope like that
wit porn was hard to come by back then
you just had to like sit there and
record things and wait and slow mo and
pause cause I were drugged in a pop-up
video you figure it out
sometimes sometimes you're watching a
part of the video no like dad is hot and
then a [ __ ] pop up the pop of video
fat comes up and you're like no not
there why are they put it there oh I
thought you would Dirk off to it because
you like the facts that would pop no no
no I think like damn these facts are
[ __ ] they're gonna buy up like pop-up
porn you know like the ads pop up
yeah when you said Papa Papa videos Oh
old so come on be a vh1 format oh I
didn't have cable I didn't know that yes
so they used to sew music videos were
all sexualize because they wanted little
kids to watch it I know that
yeah [ __ ] yeah you don't take y'all
curves adolescents to watch this [ __ ]
why do you think they [ __ ] dirtied
Christina up you think they did it for
the [ __ ] construction worker guys no
they did it to catch up to Britney
Spears honestly for you I know but who
was watching Britney Spears mostly
Britney Spears all adolescents Jaden hi
girls
that's one saying no I remember being
like 10 years old and going like
programming all the turnbuckles I saw
this [ __ ] mean and it was a picture
of like a bunch of 10 year olds at a
party like dancing and it says to the
window to the wall to the sweat drip
down my balls and it was like 10 year
old me at a friend's birthday party that
was literally us that's so funny
except for I was a freshman year yeah
everyone except for my wife she wouldn't
get that she didn't have any friends
really probably on a line form she seen
me with a [ __ ] M&M hat like talking
about what's her favorite lyrics to the
wall to the sweat drop down my ball I
can't believe it my parents let me
listen I'm like and I'm singing it in
the car my moms like you know what I
think it is though I think that either
they don't care after a certain point
which is probably true or my dad can't
understand rap lyrics my mom - she's
like out what they're saying I think
they could have been like [ __ ] - Pauly's
[ __ ] the [ __ ] cops and [ __ ] hate
police I know I don't like the beat but
uh you know it's like a different
language to them yeah yeah that's also
one of the perks of having parents that
that don't English isn't their first
language because I'm a nerd
yeah I remember you in the car wrapping
like every word of what's your fantasy
ludicrous like loud like in my mom's
face and heard it like laughing and me
being stupid you know I'm saying cuz she
didn't know what the song was about my
grandma was like you could listen to
anything just not rock music cuz that's
the devil's music and I'm like that's
cool grandma cuz I just want hip-hop and
she's like okay that's why [ __ ] you
[ __ ] Marnie she bought me some
cassettes Ice Cube and there's people
holding guns like always were friendly
people she didn't know I once told my
mom that half of all songs are about
eating [ __ ] and she pulled the car over
and I think one of the songs my dad
turned off was um was a limp Biskit and
Method Man
shut the [ __ ] up even on the radio was
like and then my dad was like that's not
good but the radio was that just shows
how great a man your dad is that he knew
limp Biskit sucked back then oh it did
the first one that came out with a hit
George Michael cover faith on rolling
rolling I wasn't a failure oh my god
that's an ass Rock if I ever heard of it
I like the outfits that girls were
wearing a wife-beater with the of course
yeah of course and the red hat yeah
signature [ __ ] anyway this story was
about static clean so I've been with you
and your underwear I think it was
probably something like this and then
yeah I don't know I just felt something
here and I pulled it out I'm like off
that is no magic trick
yeah but girls are pretty versatile
right like I've seen Nikki change in the
car without taking anything off were you
doing some [ __ ] like that you're taking
underwear often ends up on your wrist
see and girls can play it off where it's
like it's a thong Oh spreadsheet guy
[ __ ] you can't really [ __ ] take like
a random like timberland boots and like
foam jockeys and put it in that Oh hair
pin do it beanie sucks yeah so this mom
she ended up creating a Facebook group
static underwear group victim of static
clean away what's one of the funniest
ones there's just a lot of people
talking about how their thong
came up being mainly thongs don't just
it's so small yeah and it didn't get
stuck yeah and then husbands being like
yeah honey your dildo that clung to my
pants I think yeah I wasn't done honey
your dildo somehow find its what found
its way in my [ __ ] yeah it's in my
ass you got to pull one of those little
sheets in the dryer next time babe that
D cleans the whole thing that what if
that's what it's worth it was for smell
Oh daddy clean really good so they say
if you have really really staticky hair
you can like one of the hacks is to put
it on your hairbrush and limbs
oh so Nick's on the soft metal thingy
the shoes yeah it'll dry your shoes sure
so wipe your dildos off with one of
those next time instead of you know you
won't find my ass anymore if it'll
become day then you see it in the mouth
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]